I knew nothing of what anybody was doing
in my 20s I didn't know if they were
winning losing going out not going out
unless they walked into the [ __ ]
liquor store which some of them did I
literally had no [ __ ] idea get quiet
and focus on your own [ __ ] you got your
perspective
[Music]
hey everybody really excited about this
interview so far everybody's watching on
LinkedIn let's put in your phone numbers
we're gonna call somebody in LinkedIn
live put in your phone number and your
question and then the team's gonna pick
which ones but I have the super handsome
wildly accomplished Daymond John in the
building say that when I'm right nice
and Milli Vanilli's I like that right
I'm excited about that blame it on the
rain power shift when's this out
Washington March 10th
it's February 24th of recording it's
probably on a couple days so do you want
us to launch if you have any preference
and launching we'll figure that out
after Damien's got a new book it's
called power shift I'm excited to be
with him we've jammed a bunch there's at
one point we're gonna be very old men
and look back to our films together and
yeah that's gonna be fun obviously a
wildly accomplished entrepreneur star
one of the stars of shark tank but more
importantly for me ivory I'm starting to
get really like weird as I get older
meaning I've gotten very focused even
recent times even more around kindness
and like who do I want to be around
right just genuine like I saw you very
recently maybe four to seven eight ten
weeks ago at a keynote that we were both
we were both speaking at an event and I
saw you for a brief second because you'd
spoken I would was the green was running
up and like it's really interesting I
was on stage there just kind of
announcing me we saw each other adapt it
up and as I was walking on stage it was
I literally was speaking to myself
before I said hello to the crowd of like
it's really funny when you like somebody
what happens with your chemicals in your
body it happened what I just saw you
know Lobby and it's happening right now
I like nice yeah and so for all your
accomplishments obviously I don't know
you all the way through and haven't been
in enough situations but for me
personally from what I know I really
appreciate your niceness and I think
you're a nice human that's the nicest
thing I can say and so I'm glad you're
on the show I think the same here I
think they're longer each other you know
we've we've been we've talked about
getting the families together but you
and I probably realized actually ain't
gonna happen or will it right
it's all gonna happen now and that's
that I talked about it with you
you look good the show so far you know I
just turned 51 yesterday I thought I was
thank you I thought I was gonna wake up
a little smarter and I thought the
world's gonna change and I'm a little
disappointed man I was calling today
more on Monday because I got a question
for you man please why are people so
[ __ ] stupid
there's a lot of [ __ ] stupid people
out there well how do you mean it well
here's what happened well how do you
define stupid I'm stressed today the
first day of 51 cuz people still morons
I put up something that I saw on media
black something something something and
it broke down and said you know what do
you realize that the inspiration for
x-men for Stan Lee was Malcolm X and
Martin Luther King I didn't know that
Magneto's Malcolm X destroy the world
welcome they they don't like us and more
and uh Xavier is chill out the
inspiration for stay is that true
so let's [ __ ] clue I'm not gonna jump
around and just assume right I go and do
my research I find various articles
History Channel with people I put in a
link in my bio and I represented Stan
Lee for the last five years before he
passed as licensing his name I called
his family and said is this true
everybody confirmed that's neat
most of the people on there said I
didn't I didn't knows who I didn't know
too but it was about 5% I see I'm sorry
I'm not fired now [ __ ] I think I'm
following you posted this posted this
and when you're saying show me that I
said you want to go to my limit check
this out I mean comments in the most
common show pictures obviously I'm
pretty confident been around some really
great people
yep half of the half of the morons out
of the 5% were it's not sure about 2.5
percent so - but it's not true okay
these are the people that are the only
get one source of information from any
place in every place and do you think it
was a racist statement like just
probably right yes on both sides because
the ones who said it wasn't sure will
happen not to be of african-american
descent okay
the other half happened to be of
african-american descent said well then
why didn't he just yeah all right number
one if he would have made them black
this has been called the Martin Luther
King and Malcolm X chronicles and we've
already seen that how he was going down
he got inspired doesn't mean the entire
context of the entire body of x-men is
Malcolm X and Martin Luther King and the
other half of the ignorant ones just
didn't do their home it's right there in
front of you all you have to do is read
the link and then go and do your
research I think this is why what what
but here's the good news if there's more
morons like that than you and I and the
hard-working people watching this with
common sense and homework and busting
their ass can survive can no 35 you know
it's really interesting where my brain
goes on this I'm I'm deeply and but like
you know it's funny like I don't know
like I understand what you're saying
period next sentence it's wild to me how
much that doesn't upset me it actually
like it doesn't upset me
I just humans are humans you know I'm
grateful more when I see stuff like that
I'm more grateful because I've been
thinking a lot about like what makes
somebody not like something yeah and
when I see anybody not liking look I
think the big you know it makes me
grateful than I do like I'll give you a
good example I was just thinking about
this and it's perfect with you like
every time you're winning as an
entrepreneur right and there's a world
way now where entrepreneurs are
superheroes yeah right yeah and let's
call it there's 500 entrepreneurs that
probably have attention at a superhero
level
some people are Superman and and
spider-man you know Jeff Bezos ulamahs
other people are you know rogue from
x-men like there's everyone sits in a
spot it's been really interesting I'm
uncomfortably competitive like I wildly
want to win at all times
however in parallel as a contradiction I
think the world is so abundant that I
really cheer for people when they get
wins I love it yeah like I want to win
and
do I think I'm competing with every
other intrapreneur I do at the same
token I know I'm not competing with any
other entrepreneur in the world is
abundant anyway this is one long-winded
thing to save like if you have the
energy to dislike or hate or drag down
or tear down buildings shit's not good
in your soul it's true but if you are
just not even going to the point of
hating I don't think they hate it they
just made comments without doing their
research now what's going on in their
life because we base it around listen
maybe somewhat people super successful I
don't know but they're like why don't
you look and say it's whether it's hate
it's like it's like the energy the
energy to try to tear something else
down yeah whatever you want to call it
it's faster
I think the greatest thing is happening
right now the Internet in its current
state people call it social media call
it whatever you want the Internet in its
current state is exposing human beings
at a level we've never seen before so
Lee and everyone thinks everything is
super bad and I think this is the
beginning of the greatest era of the
human race I genuinely believe that I
genuinely believe that the fact that
we're now getting a better view of
ourselves is gonna lead to very
interesting good behavior hundreds of
years but really the more the data the
more information is out there the more
you can scrape it was like oh now it
sucks cuz social media FOMO all there
some like we've always been insecure
wolverson 99% of people are insecure
yeah or whatever it's 92 or 79 and a
stunning amount of people are insecure
and when you're insecure the way to mask
that is to buying things to disguise it
and tearing down others judgement yeah
well there it is so there it is I'll be
honest with you I'm more pumped because
that makes I'm like thrilled that now I
know how the x-men was inspired which is
[ __ ] epic so so and many who go on
and obviously do well the ones one other
one now this is where I need to
fact-check cuz I haven't had time I had
heard it right after I posted it that
when he did Black Panther I believe they
said something in the nature of like in
three series zero five and maybe we
could check it while we're here hey you
need to have some people of other colors
and white people in you know with the
black path
I think so I believe heat the next one
he put in was it the Black Panther
beating up the KKK so but we have to
fact-check that one we have the worst
first appearance was what in Fantastic
Four die nail that let's go yeah why'd
you write this book why'd I write this
you're under contract and you need to
bang him out no no no I'm Dyslexic and
you know so I wrote this book because it
was about one week that I got as we all
get out things from people all time and
they were asking me how to create change
in their lives and I've seen you say it
often you're not gonna do anything right
after I tell you this right yes I'm
right and they were all using and
masking it with well here's my job
here's this and that you know Warren
Buffett's has some really amazing you
may go throughout various aspects of
your life but the only thing that you
are fully in control of is yourself and
I realized that people just didn't
understand what they can do today to
make them better for tomorrow and then
next day and the next day and it was all
about negotiation I think that this the
the thing that makes me or somebody else
more successful let's say it's all of
the aspects of what we negotiated in
life
first of all with ourselves second of
all with the surrounding and the in the
families or whatever the case is third
of all with our position listen I was
born black that's not gonna change I'm
not gonna be Chinese white or yellow
tomorrow that is what it is yeah that's
what it is get over it move forward use
it as an asset in any place that I can
whatever the cases so people always
thought that negotiation and those
things that nature to create change is
either you having all the power or
somebody else taking the power from you
or they gotta give it to you and it's
the deep unhappiness exact the second
you think somebody else is in control
you're in a big trouble
when something doesn't control your
destiny run big show about this a lot
and I obviously falls into race and
gender issues but I actually think about
it parenting dynamics so much and it
happens when and this is a three-part
you have to build influence you have to
then negotiate and you have to nurture
over long relationship because this part
of the relationship we've just had
created some kind of value
it's nothing comparison to here
and it has to all be concise and I don't
think people understand it so if
somebody said bombing the elevator would
Gary be I never thought I'd see care
who's in Oklahoma I never thought I'd
see Gary Vee in my life how am I gonna
build influence with him when I got 90
seconds listen first of all make sure
the pitch you say really quick is you
know what's in it but Gary how you've
been doing really well with it and the
fact that you're gonna be successful
with or without a monopolist if you can
have if you can offer some opportunity
to them let them know your influences
when Gary and his team is gonna go back
and look at the [ __ ] you've been saying
for the last 10 years on social media
good bad or indifferent they're either
gonna say I want this person around me
or I don't want this person around me
and it's not just you you're hanging out
with this person right here who you
would never bring to Gary's office
because he's an alcoholic or a
misogynist or racist pig stop taking
pictures with him posting them all over
your side cuz Gary's not just looking
there
Gary's looking everywhere around you and
people don't understand how on points
the influence was that they had to build
prior to then negotiating and then
valuing the relationship and simple stop
simple when it's quiet in one's head
right like I was thinking a lot about
this like I wanted to ask you this how
quiet and slow are things for you and
here's how I'm saying it like you hear
athletes talk about when the game slows
down yeah I'm manic in my schedule and
my comic you know I'm also an extrovert
by nature and so there's a lot of things
that go on with my energy and I wish
there was a way that I could explain to
people how slow everything feels to me
same here good that's why we cease on
the road so much and people ask why do
we do it why why shouldn't I do it you
know if you like it that's that's why
I'm tweaking my life and I'm making sure
that all right family needs to come out
here and you spend more time here and
you do more this off I need more great
people around me a lot of more Robins so
I'm Batman and they're Robin there Rob
and I'm Batman half the time I need I
need more because I'm not gonna die I'm
not going anywhere what am I gonna do
and I'm educating myself while I'm out
there
I'm expanding my network can you explain
to the kids out here how crazy you feel
at 51 how young and alive you feel like
does that scare that 18 year old you
could you have ever imagined being this
fresh at 51 you know I was thinking like
you know I always tell the story I know
cousin Bobby was in my dad's liquor
store when I got there he'd been there
since he was 18 he was 30 when I was 22
and got there full-time
I thought he was so [ __ ] old 30
seemed like I don't wanna hang out with
the youngsters that worked for me I'm
like I get it like that
I always laugh I'm like man I think like
like I think Johnny chase and I are the
same and they think I'm [ __ ] like
their dad and I'm like no no we're
homies like brother is there no dad and
I'm like I laugh about that because I'm
44 30 seemed oldest [ __ ] knowing cut of
your roots it must blow you away I've
been in the 35 week this is a new year
so I've been in 35 cities amazing but
there for half of the month
Golden Globes McGregor fight Oscars
Super Bowl you know whatever the case is
speaking and then hang it then take my
family Bahamas and then Carnahan you for
a witness it's great speed it's great
that's great and yeah it did
real quick apologize I'm gonna get a
little more about what this is about but
I want to use most of the majority of
the 20 to 30 minutes that you know to
answer some questions so look regardless
of what the books about here's your
chance to ask Damon a question so
putting your phone numbers on LinkedIn
we're about to get some going in a
minute but I want Damon to listen
anybody in our community listen I'm not
this person but if you're the person
that actually learns from books if
you're part of this community I find it
highly unlikely that whatever discounted
price on Amazon or Barnes and Nobles or
where the [ __ ] you can find us then it's
not gonna be worth that ROI if you know
how to get information out of book form
so I highly recommend you picking it up
because I know this too doesn't put down
bad product but like Damon for the
people that are like a [ __ ] that like I
don't want to spend 16 bucks like if you
can go narrow I'm till why this book
versus just following you on social or
anything in that nature is there
anything what how are you for me when I
write books I'm able to go deeper on
this [ __ ] that I'm putting out headlines
on and go narrow and then thus I think
it's worth 16 bucks I always think that
way how do you think about this yeah so
so first of all of course you could get
any information for me free all the time
CNBC ABC
you know on my social media yeah but of
course of course absolutely but if you
want to go narrow and deep on how to
basically create influence and then how
to negotiate and how to develop those
relationships then this goes granular
into it I have about ten subjects in
there who have all went from industry to
industry and become Titans in various
different industries Pitbull mybama
sauce skies Kris Jenner a Billie Jean
King who changed the face of tennis so
so this is not just you know a change
the face of like women women and sports
right so this is obviously you are in my
last book I only take subjects out that
I can learn from on the same path as you
are in this you know what I'm talking to
somebody about negotiation a lot of
people don't realize this is really easy
because of social media people talking
five different ways and they communicate
in poverty replaces sight sound sight
sound touch taste and smell and it's
very simple if you're on social media
you can look through people's feeds and
you want to talk to them it's like a
used car salesman use cross something
you walk into the room he starts to
listen or she starts to listen how
you're communicating alright there's a
red Corvette there it has a top down if
your about site he goes can you see
yourself driving down the road look at
the leaves falling and and I want to own
a winding road if you're about to smell
is like can you smell the rich leather
yeah you know can you smell the air in
the crisp air you're about sound can you
hear the engine roaring that you see in
there's various ways of communication
you see us do it all the time with shark
tankers 65% of communications you know
is body language the only 7% is exactly
what you're saying and the rest is how
you set it right and there's various
different ways to indicate and go
through a negotiation that's why when I
get deals I can see when the person
putting their hand their pocket putting
the hair over the air Roberts sitting up
and he closes book you know what's the
name Kevin O'Leary always wants to put
something in between you to create the
distance and there's a lot of
information in this book of keys on a
way to communicate build influence and
then nurture that relationship to get
way more after that I love that let's
get some phone numbers in who's the
first person Ronnie all right while he's
rotting up all right
yeah that's interesting so you think
that there's a lot of there's a lot of
nuggets in this book that you take away
two and three and for them they just
helped you close one deal one deals ry+
[Music]
they let you get the remote control away
from your wife or husband Rodney its
Gary Vaynerchuk you're on with Daymond
John I'm great
rod are you from well you put your phone
number LinkedIn so worked out looking
forward to that by the end beginning of
next year to be certified for things
what advice would you have for you like
internet internet feel there aren't
gonna take forever playing football read
the name of Phil right now what he's
starting out you know being so close to
the game what advice would you give me
you know they become well let me give
you my take and then see if you can fill
out some spots so the biggest thing I've
learned AJ has been in the business now
for four years Feiner sports the biggest
thing that's really honest is that it's
a lot more simple than you think like I
keep watching us loose let me go a
different route the players that we lose
to other agencies were we're offering
disproportionate more impact financially
and infrastructure wise strictly because
that player liked a different agent more
than the agent we put in front of them
whether that's AJ or Brandon Parker or
Tommy or Brian you will be blown away my
man of how much of this is strictly
being liked you will be blown up you're
gonna go into this business and be
discouraged because you're gonna be like
wait the five biggest firms back to what
Damon said he's not gonna change he was
black I'm not gonna change that I
started it at
I was not athletically inclined or
educationally inclined which made
everybody from the 70s and 80s feel like
[ __ ] if you for the first 18 years of
your life like like that doesn't change
and I'll tell you this no when you get
into the game if you start small or a
small firm you're gonna go what every
agent does which is like woe is me
it's ca it's rock nation by time you get
into it we're like on our way we have 13
guys in this craft it's been written
we're gonna be a player but the reality
is I'm watching people strictly pick
people unlike ability nothing else not
what they can do like plenty people go
to rock base because they want their
selfie with jay-z plenty people go to
Vayner sports because they want business
and life after football and off the
field stuff plenty people go to athletes
first cuz Mulligan is a great agent and
they built a think that like there's a
lot of places where people go I am
stunned and I mean stunned on how many
people go with the person they liked the
most like real quick and I'll let you
jump in Jamin good news you're gonna
talk yourself out of all the things
you're gonna talk about all these other
things that you need to do all we need
to get marketing right we need to be
social media right I gotta get some of
my homies I played with football Coase
I'm you're gonna think about a million
other things that you're gonna learn
matter and I'm telling you fifty [ __ ]
percent of it is do human beings like
you and if you actually lean into that
mentally you're gonna get real happy
because you're gonna realize that you
don't have to work on all these things
that you think you have to work on Damon
yeah I mean I think it's about the same
thing I mean you gotta go narrow and
deep when you're targets that you want
and like he was saying you're gonna
you're gonna go everywhere but I think
also the co-signing of the people that
you already know that really do like it
you could tell us you're likeable but
everybody's gonna be on their first date
telling you you know your baby's
beautiful right or they're beautiful you
got to dig deep into your into your your
dad database and go after one two key
players that like you and that you like
and that you can bring value to and just
keep having these other people also
close on you like you said you're gonna
try to get all the people just get one
or two people that real
really mess with you to dig deep and
you've got of course be out there doing
your homework and be ready to pound the
phone so those cats and let them see
that you're ready just put in the hours
I'll give you two more insights cuz I'm
really want you to win one everybody
matters I went through this whole thing
of like the parents matter the parents
don't matter the you know the uncle
matters the uncle doesn't matter the
trainer matters the trainer doesn't
matter the coach matters that here's the
rule every [ __ ] person matters
because they're influencing these are
young kids and then finally complete and
utter detachment you're gonna get your
heart broke some kids gonna tell you
you're this guy all the way through all
the way through all the way through and
then it's gonna come to signing day then
they're gonna call you and be like yeah
I'm going to southern firm I'm sorry
[Music]
[Music]
yeah you can go to pool calm and get
that yeah it can make a comeback it all
depends on how much energy that I want
to put into and I have other partners
that have been putting energy into it
but it absolutely could make a comeback
it won't be on the same platform as
before just in retail it probably should
be a subscription service or or one of
those things and absolutely there's a
lot of content out there there's a lot
of history it's a global brand but we
need to get our ducks in order - thanks
for the question yeah I mean what an
iconic brand it is and I'm with you on
that all right let's get another one in
yeah man I'm shocked how much these kids
are smarter than ever but yet there was
one kid who's like logically talked me
through while why we were
disproportionate for him and then he
said but I'm going to another guy
because it was love at first sight who's
this cuz something we're good
man I'm totally humble - even if you got
right now do deploy the sanam Thank You
c'n as well
so right now you know I was in Brooklyn
I was with my with my mom and my sister
and my foot brother three months live in
one one single room no housing no how
old are you keep going
I'm 20 I just I just graduated school
some time to figure out life right now
so I don't know that I want to go with
the real estate best thing that's that's
really where I seem like my business why
you know don't forget do it
why simply because I feel like I need to
makes a lot of people and also on the
flip side not having like a home like
where I could really just kind of be
myself and you know kind of expand
that's really also something that I just
kind of know I want to be on be able to
give other people that that opportunity
in order to you know have a nice playful
is like the biggest struggle for me has
been it was pretty much the energy like
that and like in the house in the way so
just trying to figure out you know what
is did that I could do just to kind of
be a hot bath off his back back in
school mean I was I was crushed their
left and right you know I was pretty
much manifesting everything that I
wanted to and now it's doing it's hard
for me to take action
why did feel like the negative
influences of like my parents and stuff
like that why are you still home is it
that you're taking care of your parents
are they disabled or anything like that
well clean your 22 just the kind of you
know they stay at home for a good like
hood but right now but if you yeah
I'm sorry please finish yeah you know
whether or not I got you go ahead and
write that in the parvis like I know
are you I mean it's really interesting I
almost feels like you're having a
logical and an emotional conversation
with yourself which i think we all do I
love that you're thinking about saving
and you have the humility at 22 to be in
your home which I love are you also in a
place where are your parents negative by
name
sure like is that like [ __ ] you up
yeah look that's really what's really
worth living on my mom and my dad
separated and I was super young okay my
mom has been she put forth four kids
through college by herself
at least means less than $20,000 a years
East super challenging for her to kind
of balance everything that's gonna work
that a negative mindset comes from and
are you are you are you helping her yeah
or are you saving because that's she's
an amazing og mom but she just happens
to have you know through all that
adversity some negative vibes that are
potentially [ __ ] you up right please
that's that's what I thought she's proud
did you happen to see the post I put
over the weekend about this concept of
like build your crew find other hungry
people and live an hour and a half
outside the city and like did that did
what do you when you saw that what did
you think about doing that the only
thing you know I do have a lot of loser
friends but there's also don't out
partying that's what most kids do my age
when I posted when I posted the second
post where I said take over my account
everybody and find your people and the
hundreds of people that post it in there
they're from New York did it cross your
mind to DM like all of them be like yo
do you wanna do you want to room up or
was it what made you not think that for
me like I'm very cautious that's like
who I interact with I respect that
directly but I respect that because I
feel like you know for me though about
like having like the right energy and I
guess kind of like limiting myself but
aren't you but aren't you in that
scenario saying no before you even met
the [ __ ] person yeah cuz all you're
saying is your family has negative
energy and your friends are losers so
you have no other option you can only go
up by moving in with a bunch of guys or
girls I mean you know people come over
here from other countries and ain't got
time to play they're coming over here
and they're living in something for $50
a week or and they're
busting their ass and their full
buildings of them in New York of dancers
and talented peaceful and tech people
why aren't you giving that a shot just
for a month at least you know like like
where are you fighting you know what the
way the answers came out is my the thing
that I spent a lot of time thinking
about is why are people saying no before
they've tried and and the reason they're
saying no is they're either not
interested in actually putting in the
work or they're insecure and they're
fear-based which is okay there's nothing
wrong with that I'm just trying to
really help like bring value on this
call and I'm trying to really break down
like are you all so negative by Nature
you know which is which is also fine
like I really mean that like I I'm
trying to get like I want judgment out
the [ __ ] window
I want like assessment and action right
like I'm not judging listen me being
positive and optimistic is literally
completely predicated on the fact that
my parents had sex at that exact moment
and gave me that DNA it's I've no pride
and that I'm optimistic that was [ __ ]
chance City USA so as a matter of fact
that that leads to gratitude and guilt
and deep humility and compassion for
others because guess what my sister is
not bad and I've watched her like I have
more III respect my sister more than me
the things those things came natural to
me like I respect the fact that I got
into shape more than that I have all
these talents cuz I actually feel like I
worked for that this was gifted you just
like you sing no for the other party by
the way I fully agree with you I do not
think that you should live with people
that you don't jive with you [ __ ]
decided that every person that left a
comment in my post was negative energy
you said no before you said yes yes I
did the reverse I did the reverse when I
am when I first started fool we
fortunately have a house I went to work
to Red Lobster for anywhere about 50
hours a week and I would then come home
work on FUBU for 30 hours a week I would
sleep three nights three hours a night I
had sewing machines in my living room
and I slept next to sewing machines and
I rented out my bedroom and all the
bedrooms in my house for $25 a piece
because I wanted both be two strangers
to pay the mortgage and they helped pay
the mortgage I was getting money over
Red Lobster
for my day job and that helped me do
food for five years I would have to do
two million dollars in sales and food
were to make the same amount of money I
walked away with and I wouldn't have
done that and I wouldn't have had boob I
just have to make another sacrifice and
some people pay some people didn't I got
robbed in my hallway my bathroom wall
away one day
it is what it is but you know I kick
people out and that's it man I mean you
know you just have to you have to act
okay can I see you a question yeah how
much entitlement or not entitlement do
you think you have like from a
self-assessment because I think I think
a lot about this it's a really difficult
question to ask somebody like hey how
entitled are you nobody wants to be like
aw super [ __ ] entitled but on the
flip side I do think entitlement and
humility is an interesting framework for
all of us to go through because if
you're lucky enough on it then in order
to figure it out it can be really good
you know I I grew up my whole life you
know pretty much having nothing like
literally there were days where I
wouldn't even he is all right I don't
know we'd have meals that I had up in
school and I'm so long but wait those
kind of you know eight hours 10 hours we
go to breakfast run over and then just
kind of go from there so that's I mean
super humble you know just being a per
degree from appreciative of what I
didn't have you know but back in school
back in college people always tell me
it's like the positive person there's no
honey I was never negative or anything
like that I feel like being home I'll be
honest you have maybe slightly more
negative now I mean the second time you
know that energy just kind of like rubs
off on me so right now it's really kind
of my entitlement I feel like I got it I
get a little more title in the sense
that like hey like why can't I just have
like a regular place to live in the way
we just haven't we're just negative
energy come from but but you can but you
can write like like I guess my question
is like have you got caught up in like
New York's expensive and I have no
options right and do it I'm sorry I got
a little distracted do you have a job I
do
okay so [ __ ] commute longer bro
really project broke
mute further mm-hmm like who the [ __ ]
said you had a live in Williamsburg
Bushwick or Manhattan you know like what
like there's people at vaynermedia that
commute two and a half hours to be here
I don't know like like this is where I'm
going it's an infinite and I'm coming
from love and I hope you can feel it
like and I feel like you could pick it
up - I'm excited about this like I'm
trying to like on some real option [ __ ]
like why not move far as [ __ ] and
commute two hours every morning okay I
can see this piece of what I'm hearing
and this is a hot takeoff of [ __ ]
nine minutes and 40 seconds I think that
you should definitely get out of the
house alright and so for me whether it's
Union New Jersey which you're
arbitrarily picking like dude it sounds
like you're very far away from real
estate investing no yeah I just think
there's a huge opportunity for you to
live further away where you can afford
it and you're good I think people pick
convenience and like to me like an extra
hour commute for that mental happiness
is like a monster win for you you were
the [ __ ] man at school because you
had freedom I'm just like cool we won
this game move an hour further away get
a little less sleep or a little less
convenience on that hour commute the
extra power on the train you get a lot
of [ __ ] done and you can be happy as
[ __ ] yeah that makes sense to you right
cuz that's why I asked about entitlement
like yes I know you want to save and I
love you for that I [ __ ] love you for
that
you've also assessed that the
environments negative so I'm like wait a
minute you can win both here you can
really drive down your rent if you're
just willing to live an hour and a half
from the city this is New York City
expensive place if you go an
hour-and-a-half commute outside of here
[ __ ] gets cheaper we don't necessarily
know the mom is negative mom busted I
asked to put poor kids through college
maybe she's telling him some [ __ ] you
don't want to yeah either but you know
you never know either way he got to go
out and do it on his own whether she's
right or he's right he just needs to
eliminate another excuse right to her
point she might by the way say okay I
think you might know this she might be
right
it's actually irrelevant you're on it
Damon like she's a g4 single mom put
four [ __ ] people through school she's
a [ __ ] gangster let there be no
confusion her execution and doesn't want
anything now
are you kidding a [ __ ] gangster now
now it's a small space it's a small
space all I want you to do is eliminate
the excuse of your mom I'm telling you
this not because I'm [ __ ] on her I'm
actually [ __ ] on the situation and
I'm hopeful that if you move an hour and
a half out this is notice what I asked
you how entitled are you that's amazing
so good news move out and make it
inconvenient
yeah like like like if you're truly
trying to save money and now you've
taken on a 500 or a thousand dollars
more of expenses all of a sudden every
nice little thing you like has to be
looked at good man
don't buy books
the Internet's free is [ __ ] like I'm
being serious like every book like
pirate up Pirate Bay like pirate that
[ __ ] go Google [ __ ] POW go look at
power shift and crush it on [ __ ]
pirate bay or if that's still around
this [ __ ] steel
steal that [ __ ] let's not oh you're
seeing doors iron doors over water
absolutely like I'm [ __ ] 15 dollars on
the Amazon when you [ __ ] or building
in the beginning don't buy [ __ ] people
don't wanna save anymore you know what's
happened you know what's happening right
now this is where you're gettin caught I
think tell me if I'm wrong the fact that
you're not paying rent and saving is
allowing you to spend money on a couple
things that you wouldn't have and that's
where the cycles play I believe I
believe you then then I would say for
happiness instead of this happening in
11 years let it happen in 14 years by
moving an hour and a half out again and
stuff like that
no I feel like it's just a lot of people
who like don't care about saving and in
just you know every every other day
going after dreams oh [ __ ] they're like
there's nothing who gives a [ __ ] right
that's good I like when everybody else
is doing dumb [ __ ] that means I'm about
to win what do you feel it wait a minute
wait a minute
are you telling me that you feel FOMO
when everybody goes out on [ __ ]
thirsty Thursday and drinks a [ __ ]
mojito bro let me tell you let me tell
you something really good don't judge
anyone okay you see where I'm going I'm
watching a lot of judgment come out now
I'm starting to spend some time with you
like if we were having a for our dinners
homies I'm like bro stop judging oh he
going judge do you after you
like you see one goin no bro and I got
love for you to like honestly be
empathetic like be grateful that you're
not in a mater like I what when I talk I
you know I've been trying to tell people
I don't have advice I have I'm like
every other human we're animals that
like to share hypotheses opinions are
hot takes but like like don't judge them
yeah and don't don't envy them I hate
when people like damn yeah cuz there's
dad's pain for a [ __ ] he gets to go to
the club and deep down he [ __ ] thinks
he's a loser because his dad's paying
for everything next next like like oh
damn they're just buying those drinks or
those clothes to fit in don't judge them
feel bad for them that their whole life
is about other people's [ __ ]
acceptance so they have to [ __ ] ruin
their own lives just so everybody thinks
they're cool I think you're spending a
lot of time on judgment don't even think
about it I knew nothing I knew nothing
over to anybody was doing in my 20s I
didn't know if they were winning losing
going out not going out unless they
walked into the [ __ ] liquor store
which some of them did I literally had
no [ __ ] idea get quiet and focus on
your own [ __ ] does that make sense to
you okay okay I'll tell you something
else
you're probably judging cuz there is a
little underlining envy and FOMO which
is okay because we're humans yep you see
where I'm going and that's okay for me
like you're impatient you're six [ __ ]
my you're eight but sin we all were
impatient though with that age hold on
let's create some clarity cuz I know a
little bit about your narrative yeah
don't confuse ambition with lack of paté
you were patient yeah I was patient okay
out but I will pay outpatient but I was
patient because I was making as many
moves and mistakes as I could and I was
saying alright this is this is moving
forward I kept moving that's different
than when you're impatient and you start
[ __ ] like looking at
from an egg were you were happy and
patient too many people are sad and
impatient because they can't wait to get
to the finish line without [ __ ] even
warming up bro you're 40 seconds in yeah
what do you think you're gonna be a
[ __ ] real estate tycoon by 24 with
the [ __ ] go to sleep for the next 10
year don't even call me until you're 32
and don't talk to nobody go to sleep go
hibernate for a decade and just [ __ ]
eat [ __ ] and work and be patient and
then maybe kind of sorta at 32 youngest
[ __ ] maybe we can have a conversation
about something maybe everybody's
[ __ ] deciding at 22 your [ __ ] 18
months out of school I knew I wanted a
[ __ ] Superbowl is the owner of the
New York Jess so I decide to be patient
for 52 [ __ ] years I knew - good news
me too
now what I didn't say a peep I [ __ ]
work to the liquor store the [ __ ]
basement for 15 years before I even
popped my head up to make a youtube
video didn't say a word didn't go to a
club didn't buy [ __ ] [ __ ] work and
punch line built it for my dad and
started over in a [ __ ] conference
room at 34 are you walking do you see
how Gary's eyeballs are bulging and what
I want for you is paid and you know what
I want for you patience and
self-awareness you're gonna be people
lose by him being impatient patience bro
it's super real and it's super hard
hold on before I go any further leek
ought up in this narrative schools got
the band camp he got that one day at
band camp he got that Al Bundy [ __ ] like
this because when he was in school he
was hot and sexy and now he went back to
the hood and [ __ ] and he's like
why don't you say why are you sexy at
school you were happy okay and I feel
like my stuff and everything I've been
through in my life I felt like if I
could translate that story and share it
with others and you know just kind of I
was really like kind of like a mediator
to be that 300 people are calling me
okay but you can appreciate this the
part that gets confusing about Gary Vee
to a lot of people is I [ __ ] like I'm
positive and optimistic but it's all
based on merit and execution like you
can't build a business on just being
positive and optimistic that's not my
business that's just that's my that's my
giving actually [ __ ] and he's moving
back in Banco okay do you think that's
right I'm curious I asked to put him in
the environment where he blossomed and
Bandcamp and now he's going back to [ __ ]
and wondering why aren't times good like
before okay now put my name on the milk
in the fridge don't touch that that's my
mommy
I know potential within myself and in
the way it kind of gets frustrating or
that's like being limited you know me
being at home so but here's here's the
best part
nobody's keeping you at home right
you're choosing to be at home matter
back mom's like nah don't give me none
don't give me that mom's kill on this
car
you need to leave homie I already said
holy college education more times
chef course cuz nobody wants their baby
leavin if you want yo you 16 yeah go
about your business go get that paper
bro you need to be careful here because
if she doesn't want you leaving and she
paid for your college you're getting
coddled cuz nobody else is there no no
like that has nothing to do with you
you're being coddled you know that right
do you know me people right now in my
community are like mad as hell at you
because they're in debt and they have
nowhere to go you know that right yeah
you need to be careful here in a good
way this is why this is fun like oh this
is all love as you can tell oh listen
man you need to be careful you need to
be careful here you need to be real
careful here because your mom is [ __ ]
amazing and a lot of times when I talk
about parents that create fake
environments we always paint them as
super rich white families what we don't
talk enough about is immigrants or
humble [ __ ] work their whole lives
for their kids and put their kids on and
you need to be careful here because
you're coddled and I want to see every
receipt because the second you bought
one cup of Starbucks I'm mad at you
respect respect bro but you'll but but
what up but I'm really serious on this
on you might be coddled you know that
right right like it's rare to not have
to pay rent it's rare it's rare real
quick it's rare for your parent to pay
for college completely it's rare it's
rare for you to be able to not pay rent
so you might be getting caught because
you're entitled no no your
oh yeah but your but but humility you
know comes in the form of like you
started this call with you know friends
or losers and negative energy in a home
you're not paying for that's called non
accountability humility comes with mom
how can I have more value to you what
can I do to get out of this house and
warnings done that's right and help you
with house and you're using my sibling
you're using the excuse of mom doesn't
want me to leave yeah because she says
she loves you and loves having you
around
fake environment bro I feel like even
though when I do leave I think it may
hurt her in one aspect but I feel like
when she sees that I'm doing well but
you me go away to college
tougher course bro of course parents
love their kids especially what the way
you're painting your mom here's the
other thing she's ready for you to be a
man I promise my favorite movies
stepbrothers and they lived in the house
so they were forty I got a family you
got the close out the show okay I love
you I'm being dead serious plug away for
four minutes I love her alright so
anyway so we're gonna close out man I'm
and I'm gonna take one more call but I
want you to remember the one thing power
ship is an exclusive ownership of
Daymond John it is it is watermarks any
rebroadcast and or downloading a content
illegally you will go to the chair all
the best brother Thank You Man P all
right
that's a great call I like that one with
Gary uh I don't know we went back and
forth love them hated him gotten his ass
that was really absolutely amazing
listen one more call let's do one we'll
call this next segment is brought to you
by powershift
garyvee favorite book he uses this all
the time I sent him a copy change his
life who's on MacGyver this guy I'm
gonna like it more if it's a girl yeah
MacGyver how you doing this is Daymond
John yeah I'm taking the place of
garyvee for the last call of the
broadcast how are you doing calling you
[Music]
communicating with people basically
moved up in the company and success man
but honestly a lot of it suits you guys
like yourself and Gary being you know
the pour into us and allow us to soak it
up and go get it
well that's impressive man that I
appreciate that's impressive I want
people to know that they don't
necessarily and I'm not saying
anything's wrong with college if you
can't afford and you know to go to
college people like you and me I barely
finished high school we went out there
we busted our butt and and that's that's
really honestly what the book is about
like creating influence you moved up in
the company then you said you moved up
in the company why why was it because of
purely your talents or the way you want
more people to work harder naturally
good with people I'm one of those cats
you could put me in any scenery any
block and I'll get along with anybody
what's on
yeah you don't exactly brought our
little chameleon you know capability in
a sense but and then just caring for
people grow and being genuine and honest
and then you know I started out as a
third employee when I left me at about
15 employees and I actually started that
minimum wage graphic designer 15 20
hours a week and I actually became VP of
the company and continued to grow I
think you just hit it on the head you
know when Garrett was song to the
gentleman earlier today talking about
you know being a sports agent people
need to like you I mean the whole theory
of power the whole theory of power ship
is that you have to build influence and
how do you build influence look you you
dropped out of school you went to a
company you were getting minimum wage as
a designer or assistant designer you
motive to be the VP the reality is that
whether you are you know in power shift
whether you're trying to get a better
job getting an investment from me or do
something else people want to be around
people they like people want to be
around people that they can sit next to
for eight hours a day five days a week
for the next five years and if you're a
problem solver and you shift power to
other people when you see that they can
do something and they shift power back
to you and then you nurture those
relationships you're doing exactly why I
wrote the book there's too many people
out there using as an excuse there's
people out there that would have been
you and said I dropped out of school I'm
only starting a minimum-wage I got all
these hours they're never gonna respect
me the company is only three people it's
never gonna grow 15 and that's exactly
the mentality so I thank you as well for
learning from Gary me and all the other
people out there who just take the time
to put the information out there free or
or anywhere you can find it and and I
hope you're doing the same for the
people coming up underneath you actually
been working on want to start something
called creative culture of one day and
that creative kind of stands for
community of real entrepreneurs and
aspiring Trail Blazers with
imperfections that have value and really
it's about just empowering other people
like if I can do it at the high school
dropout got two felonies when I third a
teen like the whole nine you don't I
mean should not be where I am today I
still got my
I'll ups and downs but I definitely
should not have the opportunities I've
had and if I can do it any joke slow can
you know what I mean and I want to help
those you got emissive power other
people realize while imperfect we all
got our struggle we're better together
and if we give it at that facade and
help enable one another we're all gonna
win long term I feel exactly like you do
and I want to make sure that people
listening to you needs to understand
that the mentality of an entrepreneur
can be used within a system you know
when when I'm at my company all my
people think as entrepreneurs because if
I was the only one thinking like that
these guys would just be putting you
know round pegs in round holes but if
you're an entrepreneur you think within
the system I need to depend on my staff
and people like you who think like
entrepreneurs
so Gary beans back I don't know if you
got a question for him I think we're
gonna sign off right after that we got a
great guy in here who dropped out of
school
yeah happy for you
yeah he dropped out of high school 10th
grade started minimum-wage job as a
designer in the company with three
people moved up the vice president and
is crushing it so love congratulations
thanks Damon for holding it down all
right all right by-the-book power shift
is out March 10th Ted that's good call
out if anybody hits us on a DMS I'm like
oh yeah what do you want Ted to I see a
growth hacking I like well I like it by
the way Ted saw her as an intern he's
the president of my company I listen to
Ted yeah Ted's my boss too every time I
see him I feel like I have to answer to
him too for no reason like sorry Ted
Power Shift + DM Daymond the receipt on
Instagram he will pick 10 people that
Damon will call to talk about their
business for 10 minutes I love that call
home like weird [ __ ] but ten copies DM
to Damon on his Instagram and we will
pick 10 people I love to talk to I like
to grow thank you all thank everybody
thank you Gary we thank everybody here
for investing themselves from their time
with us they could be anywhere in the
world
and they chose to be with us tonight
you